tell me what's going on with Michael
Rapaport and the um you guys are in a
football league together we're all in a
text message group together he started
yelling at everybody that they're
misusing the IR spot an injured reserve
spot that we weren't doing it right that
we're putting people that are just out
that aren't injured in our spot it's
basically you cheated
again I don't want to bore the fans but
if the commissioner had put the settings
right he would not have had the option
to do it is that correct yeah okay it's
my first year as commissioner Jason's so
worried about [ __ ] what he's eating
he couldn't help me out he said he would
help me out by the way Jason kaplan's
walking around in his suit have you seen
the way Jason dresses now that he lost
some weight he looks like James Bond
look at that sexy man oh my goodness
look at this guy look at him I'm not
used to all these nice comments thank
you well don't worry we'll say something
[ __ ] up something will come soon this
is the first time Jason's walked in the
studio and Fred hasn't played elephant
sounds
you got the A Team here today to see
everybody in person after all these
months of covet to see the stars the
icons of the Stern Show in person very
exciting I truly love these guys and the
reason why I'm here in all seriousness
is because I am a fan of the show I love
the show and uh I'm a fan of the show
that being said I am the commissioner of
your fantasy football league which is a
league that is being ran right into the
ground let me talk about that the rumor
I've heard is that you took over as
commissioner of the fantasy football
league because you felt it was being
poorly run and you were going to show
these guys how to run it and and Michael
now you're saying you're fed up you
don't like the fantasy football league
and that you are going to resign after
this year and and uh is that true
possibly
I might I might I don't know the league
itself the lack of um interaction has
become boring uh uh some week the guys
communicate some weeks the guys don't
communicate and it's just it used to be
like a like a fun thing and I feel like
people are I don't know Richard
sometimes you know we have a group text
message and I'll put some you know I'll
put some stuff out there and sometimes
no one will respond Gary Gary what does
it change every time it's like making
fun of Gary and then like none of us
respond and he's like oh you guys don't
want to make fun of Gary too I'm like no
I don't care about Gary that must have
been in front of them I think Howard for
me what I'm getting out of this is that
there's a fantasy football league right
and we're all in that and that's enough
work but Michael feels if we don't fight
all day Sunday that it's really not fun
no that's that's not Gary you like to
you want us to argue it's a fantasy
football league
150 a week I mean like let's put some
some fun so we use the banter and it
used to be fun now it's like what am I
doing am I going to win 150 this week
people have kids and lives go just give
me a break Michael you are a busy
working
Michael in all fairness I know you love
to trash talk you get off on it but it
really isn't the fantasy football league
about football and playing the game I
mean what you're looking for about
winning a championship one time it's
about the winning it's about the losing
it's about the it's really about the
camaraderie of it all that's what it's
about uh the communal aspect of of the
game of the sport